- I feel like it's quite
rare to meet someone
who's an in-house personal
slave to someone, right?
- Right.
- You wouldn't bring out the sadist in me.
- Do you wanna make a bet?
- We'll see.
- You're about to see a lot.
I kinda feel bad that he's in a cage.
Just a warning to everyone out there.
Hello?
- Thank us too.
- Thank you.
- He's about to get a
tattoo just above his penis.
- Put it on the tightest setting.
- You can look at me one last
time before I blindfold you.
- Never glad-wrapped a human before,
it's normally just leftovers.
- If you want to take your
shirt off, you're welcome.
- Do you think YouTube would allow that?
- I don't know what I
would do without this life.
- Hi there, I'm Tan,
and I'm about to spend
24-hours with Damiana who
is obsessed with power,
control, subs, doms,
whips, chains, dungeons,
and the psychology of the human mind.
- I first became obsessed
with the subject of BDSM
about 20 years ago through
a psychological standpoint.
I was assigned, in my
Masters Degree in Psychology
to choose a disorder out of the
Diagnostical Statistical
Manual of Mental Disorders.
Most of them sounded depressing,
so I chose sadomasochism.
Well I ended up writing
my doctoral dissertation
on the subject.
I just started writing
paper after paper about it.
- I think there's a difference
between having a fetish
and being obsessed with it
and when you have an in-house slave
who's lived in your
dungeon for over a decade
is kinda like bordering obsession, right?
And obviously he is obsessed with
the opposite side of this spectrum.
He is a big bottom.
I feel like I'm gonna end
up leaving Damiana's dungeon
feeling like the biggest
vanilla piece of shit,
and I can't wait.
- I'm Damiana, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Would you like me to show you around?
- I would love that.
- Room by room.
There's an edible fantasy.
Strap people to it, facing frontward.
An interrogation chair.
Something special's
gonna happen here today
that has never been done.
Maybe we will leave that as
a surprise for later, yeah?
I'm a nine to five dom.
Maybe my first session's around
10 o'clock in the morning
and I might end in the late afternoon
maybe early evening and
then my goal is to be done
by that time so I can go home
and make dinner for my children,
take them to ballet lessons, piano,
all of these things are
very important to me.
- What about this here?
- Spanking bench, would
you like to model on it?
- Maybe in a minute.
- Yes.
- Yeah, I mean definitely.
- Sure.
- But not, not right now.
What are you gonna teach me today?
- So there's a lot involved as far as
imparting knowledge about
the psychology behind BDSM.
Show you how to carry
yourself, how to speak.
There needs to be three
elements for a dominatrix
to be well-balanced.
The seductress, the mother,
and the authoritarian.
Come out here.
So you'll be kind of assisting me.
- Okay, you just mold me.
I'm just play dough right now.
- Sure, that'll be fun.
My slave Mike might be
in earshot right now,
so I'm gonna talk a little low.
- I'm Damiana's personal slave.
- [Damiana] Because it's his birthday
my sister is going to come over.
- [Tan} Your sister
Jezebel is a dom as well?
- She is, yes.
We are known as the Chi sisters,
and we are going to
finally collar him today,
and he's going to get tattooed.
And then I've got a
client of mine coming in.
So I'm gonna be putting
you in bondage and,
you up for it?
- Whatever you want.
Brilliant, brilliant.
- He's into like heavy whippings
and heavy bondage and such.
- Is he my play thing?
- Most definitely.
And then we're going to
have my slave girl come in.
- Thank you, Mistress.
My life is so awesome.
- And you can play with her as well.
I'm her Mistress.
Get on your knees.
- Yes, Mistress.
- Sort of owner and friend.
I've got the cleaning slave.
- You like cleaning?
- For Mistress I do.
- I'm gonna have him
start cleaning everything
and getting it ready for
you for the sleepover
while we go to dinner.
You know, he can do that.
- Am I okay, dressed like this?
- [Damiana] Would you like
to get dressed with us?
- There are some boundaries
that shan't be crossed.
It's something Beyonce would wear.
I don't even know what this is.
Oh, it's not a cat suit.
- [Damiana] It looks good.
This is the best part.
Collaring, spanking, and then tattoo.
- Okay.
- Okay?
♫ Happy birthday,
♫ Happy birthday to you.
- I'm Damiana's personal slave.
I'm exclusive to her.
- On your knees.
- So you're her property?
- Yes.
- And so this dungeon is home?
- This is home.
- This is a special
day, it's your birthday.
We've planned a little special
activities for you today.
We want to officially collar
you as our slave today.
- Slave Mike.
- Property of the Chi sisters.
Yes.
- Great.
- You belong to us now.
- Yeah, you're our family.
We adore you and you're special to us.
Getting emotional?
Come here.
- Your mistresses came
out with your collar.
That was a very emotional moment.
- Yes.
Yeah I would say it was
like, you know, euphoria.
- I love you.
- Happy birthday, Mike.
- Thank you.
- Now, time for your birthday spanking.
17 spanks to symbolize the number of years
that you've been serving us.
You count for us.
- One.
- Thank us too.
- Two, thank you.
- Thank you who?
- Three, thank you Mistress.
- [Damiana] Onto the
next thing on the agenda.
- Yes, Mistress.
- For your birthday.
- Do you know what she's
going to do to you?
- Probably re-mark me.
- Don't resist it, just go into it.
You've done that before with S&M right?
- Yeah, sure.
- Just do the same thing.
- What are you doing now Damiana?
- I'm tying his ankles
and pulling them down.
- Why do you think pain feels so good?
- I don't likely think it feels good,
it's like, you're suffering
for your Mistress.
But pain just for pain's sake,
I never really, really liked.
- You should really try this Tan.
It's fun.
- And I can image as time
goes on the bar just...
- I get a little concerned
that I've done everything.
- Yeah, I was gonna ask,
do you ever get bored?
Are you ever like, oh this again?
I've been bull-whipped
1000 times, what next?
- Yeah a little, although you never know
what's gonna happen and when.
That keeps you in a little suspense.
- Yeap.
- So I was thinking to do
a little flogging lesson.
A good idea for a Dom to
feel the submissive side,
you get a better understanding.
This'll be good.
- Okay.
- So are you willing?
- Yeap, okay, cool.
- And face the cross, this
is a St. Andrews cross.
Place your hands here.
So you don't want the
flogger to go like this
and wrap around.
This is the lightest flogger that I have.
I'm just going back and forth,
kind of like in a figure eight.
Everybody's sexuality is on a spectrum
of the dominance and submissiveness.
And you know you might be kind of switchy
and have both or you're
more on the submissive side.
That shouldn't be hell.
- No, kind of like at the end of a massage
when you get chopped up a bit.
- If you want to take your
shirt off, you're welcome.
- Do you think YouTube would allow that?
It sounds worse than it is.
- It does, this one does, yeah.
- I think everything is scary
before you try it yourself.
What do you think are some
common misconceptions?
- That it's dark, abusive
thing that people do
against their will.
You know, there is some darkness
but it's only there when someone wants it.
BDSM is consensual.
They call it safe, sane and consensual,
and that's how I play it.
I'm gonna change into a different outfit
because the mood of my
next session is different.
Yeah, I'm a little bit more fierce.
I'm gonna wear a hat like you.
- So we're gonna be matching.
Whoa.
- Come on in.
Follow me.
Say hello to Mistress Tan.
She just wants to feel how it is,
she hasn't actually done it on someone.
Can you do that cuff?
See how I'm doing a figure eight?
- Okay.
- You know, he can take it,
but we need to warm him up.
- So how are you feeling right now then?
- Super.
- [Tan] You went from
flogging the shit out of Max,
to hugging him.
- It's a really bonding experience.
- I would have never
thought that dominating
was so nurturing.
- The more than your submissive feels safe
in your control,
are you calling me names?
The more they let go.
It's all about trust.
- I feel like, very open.
Very much the same when you meditate,
I just feel good, feel very good.
I think she's a very intuitive person
and I think she's a healing soul as well.
And no barriers.
We've got barriers with the
rest of the world haven't we?
- There are going to be
people that are imbalanced
and they're maybe using as an outlet
but there are a lot of
psychologically imbalanced people
in the world who use
other things as outlets.
- Never glad-wrapped a human before,
it's normally just leftovers.
- And actually, recent research now,
they found that people who play in BDSM
are actually more psychologically healthy
than people who aren't.
They're actually accepting
those parts of themselves,
that's when you're a
psychologically healthy person.
The less you suppress,
the healthier you are.
- [Female Voice] Why did we act that way?
I didn't want to be afraid.
- Conditioning.
- What's conditioning?
- Come over here.
- My cleaning slave's about to arrive.
- Hello, Mistress.
- Do you have your collar?
- Tan.
She's Mistress Tan to you today.
Clean all the toys that we used.
These here, make everything neat.
Yes, Mistress.
My sister, she had an acquaintance
that was doing kind of
like slave stuff for her.
He would come over to my house,
pay me to clean my house.
- He pays you?
- Yeah he would pay me to clean my house.
- What a dream.
- It's so fun.
- Jealous.
- How about we get something to eat?
- Yes, I'm starving.
- Yeah, so am I.
Slave?
- Yes, Mistress?
- Can you put all the
clean toys in one place
and then make a big pile.
- Yes, Mistress.
- I'm gonna get changed.
- Okay.
Do you ever wish that you
led a fully vanilla life?
That you weren't obsessed with BDSM?
- I don't know what I
would do without this life.
I'm so grateful for it.
I feel so lucky.
We're going back to my
studio to meet Roxy.
She's my female play thing, she's great.
I love her.
- And what will we be doing with her?
- Spanking, maybe a paddling.
She's discovered a part of herself
that's kind of already been there
but it's being awakened.
- Kind of like what happened with you?
- Yeah, I think so, on the dominant end.
You know I don't think she would mind
if you spanked her as well.
- Okay, yeah.
What are you waiting for?
- I'm not actually sure.
- He's done an excellent job.
- Do you still have things to do?
- Actually, I am finished Mistress.
- Well there's one mistake that you made.
Did you do that?
- (mumbles)
- Well I want you to clean it.
- Yes, Mistress.
- Even if it's not your fault.
Let me see, I want you to spray it.
Come out here, hurry up.
Get down on your knees.
- Yes, Mistress.
- You know, I'm going
to report to your owner
what a terrible job you
did on that toilet seat.
I want you to lean over
that spanking horse.
- He hadn't done a good job.
- No, I was kind of
embarrassed that my toilet
looked that way having,
you know, my guests over.
The puppy appreciates
your strictness because
it needs you to teach it that way.
Apologize to me.
So it's not like I dislike
the puppy in any way,
he needs the sternness.
- It's been a big day.
Just excited to meet a female sub.
- Roxy?
- Yes, Mistress?
- I'm gonna bring you out now.
- Yes, Mistress.
- Meet our guest.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- This is slave Roxy,
and this is Mistress Tan.
So you be a good girl for her.
- Yes, Mistress.
- Mistress Tan, how you
spank is you cup your hand
a little like this.
It makes a better sound
too when you cup it.
You okay?
- Yes, yes I'm great, thank you.
- She loves it.
She does.
- Thank you, Mistress.
- She brings out
something different in me.
- Roxy was so happy.
- Yeah.
- It feels orgasmic in another level.
My life is so awesome.
It takes me to a whole
nother level mentally.
She always surprises me
with how much I can take.
So I make it feel,
especially because I'm really
like a-sexual in my personal life,
so to be able to explore here
and feel the pain through
pleasure, it's exciting.
I'm ready for the day,
but I'm going to bed.
Thank you.
- It's almost midnight,
Roxy is about to leave,
she's getting dressed.
And Mike's getting ready
to go to sleep in the cage.
- Good night, Mistress.
- Good night, slave.
I'm gonna put you to bed now.
- Yay.
- Good night.
- Sleep tight.
- You too.
- Um, where, where do we,
- Well, how was your first day?
- So much happened.
It feels like we've been invited
into this very secret private world.
- They're entrusting me in the biggest
secret that they have.
You know, possibly a
secret that nobody else
in their life knows.
- It's a big deal.
- It's a big deal, yeah.
- To be honest, at the
start and last night
I was very anxious 'cause I didn't know
how this would go down.
I just want to be somebody
else, just for a day.
It relies completely on consent,
trust and communication.
I can kinda understand now
how you would become obsessed.
One day you get flogged, the
next day you get spanked.
And of course you'd be
like, well, what's next?
You can be anyone you want,
just get the right wig.
I kind of feel bad that he's in a cage.
Are you happy?
- Oh, absolutely, for sure.
- Are you comfortable?
- Very.
- How often would you sleep here?
- I would sleep here always
if she would request that.
- Well as long as you're
comfortable and warm.
All right Mikey, well happy birthday.
- Thank you very much, appreciate it.
I'm glad that you were here to see it
and yeah, it was a lot of fun.
- All right, well good night.
- Good night.
- You ready to go to bed?
- Oh, I feel like I could fall asleep
on a pile of rocks right now
and it would just be, well, sadistic.
I'm ready.
Has it been hard to
find partners or friends
that understand that obsession?
- My husband and I
actually met in the scene.
So he actually built all
of my dungeon furniture.
That's how we met.
Obsessed might have this connotation of
only all into that but, you know,
my obsession's very healthy.
I'm expressing myself as a complete woman.
It's just the greatest.
This is much more fulfilling for me
than my psychotherapy practice
that I almost went into.
There's a limited relationship there.
You have to stay behind this barrier.
I mean there's a place for it,
I honor people that do that,
but this is, this is more me.
- I have a cool job because I
get to meet a lot of people,
they show me very intimate
parts of their lives
but I feel like this is really up there,
so thank you so much for
sharing that with me.
- You're so welcome.
It was an honor for me
too, to be with you,
and show you my life, I'm proud of it.
- You seem very happy.
- I'm very happy.
I wish everyone can
experience what I experience.
It's not for everyone,
it's definitely for me.